été 2011 sur la côte d'azur dans le var
la méditerranée saisi lé port cros
porquerolles le vent et la presqu'île
d'hyères deux mois deux mois matin et
après midi à enfiler une combinaison de
plongée mordre le détendeur inspiré un
bon coup et ya les aléas 20 40 50 mètres
de profondeur pour le plaisir et pour
apprendre
c'est un des moments les plus heureux de
ma vie vraiment je ne suis jamais senti
aussi vivante qu en allant si profond
dans la mer et pourtant malgré
l'entraînement et la prudence nécessaire
pour cette activité
le risque existe en plongée et de
manière générale en mer la mer est un
milieu hostile pour l'homme et qui
depuis les débuts de la navigation a
suscité beaucoup de craintes et fait
naître un lot de superstition avant
chaque plongée je prenais soin de placer
un petit coquillage dans la manche de ma
combinaison juste au niveau du poignet
coincé entre la peau et néoprène un
coquillage porte-bonheur un oeil de
sainte-lucie bon qu'on soit clair je
suis athée tu ne crois absolument pas en
la présence d'une entité supérieure pour
gérer le monde et j'ai toujours eu une
grande réticence face aux superstitions
et pourtant durant cet été là j'ai été
superstitieuse plongée essence gris gris
nacré et robes des à prendre un risque
supplémentaire
l'oeil de sainte-lucie n'est pas en
réalité un coquillage mélopées recul
minéralisée d'un mollusque de la famille
des turbines idée on trouve un peu
partout en méditerranée il est très
reconnaissable par sa forme ronde plein
avec une spirale faisant penser à un
oeil le nom de sainte lucie fait
référence à lucie de syracuse sainte et
martyre sicilienne souvent invoquée pour
soigner les maladies oculaires beaucoup
de peinture là représentent d'ailleurs
avec un plateau à la main sur lequel on
a placé des yeux porter sur soi cet
opéra kull éloignerait mauvais sort et
ont le vent dans pratiquement toutes les
boutiques touristiques du bord de mer à
la même époque et un peu par hasard on
m'a proposé pour mes études de traiter
cette question de la superstition chez
les marins l'antiquité gréco-romaine
projet que j'ai accepté sans même
prendre le temps d'une inspiration
vous l'aurez compris aujourd'hui j'ai
envie de vous emmener avec moi en mer
pour vous parler dans ce cadre tout à
fait approprié des superstitions mais
pas n'importe lesquels les superstitions
maritime
des superstitions en mer il y en a des
tas et ce depuis les tout débuts de la
navigation pas étonnant donc que les
marins autant ou naviguer sans
instrument à l'aide des étoiles et par
expérience est été les plus
superstitieux des hommes durant
l'antiquité les nombreux naufrages ont
fait naître chez les navigants un besoin
constant de se rassurer de mettre toutes
les chances de leur côté
et pour cela il n'y a qu'un seul moyen
de rendre culte aux dieux protecteurs
pour cette raison la plupart des navires
étaient baptisées au nom d'une divinité
qu on inscrivait sur la coque celui
d'athéna d'aphrodite de neptune était
très récurrent il ya toute une liste de
mauvais présages en milieu maritime
qu'on connaît par un texte de l'auteur
antique pétrole le satiricon dans ce
texte on apprend que certains
comportements de mauvaises augures sont
à bannir sur un bateau par exemple il ne
faut pas éternuer en montant à bord il
est aussi interdit de jurés et de danse
et d'avoir des rapports sexuels pour
raconter ses cauchemars et la présence
des femmes à bord est fortement
déconseillé parce qu'évidemment ça peut
porter malheur les anciens ont donc mis
en place des rites des cérémonies pour
remédier à tous ces mauvais présage que
je vais vous expliquer on peut dire
qu'il ya trois types de rite que l'on
dit propitiatoire ça signifie qu'ils
sont destinés à éloigner mauvais sort
les premiers se déroule à terre avant le
départ du navire pour assurer le voyage
en mer dans de bonnes conditions
on connaît bien ces pratiques pour les
navires de guerre sous l'empiré romain
l'empereur purifie la flotte militaire
avant un départ en campagne en
sacrifiant un animal ou en faisant des
offrandes à une divinité sur un hôtel
comme des libations de 20 on le voit par
exemple un clown trajane à rome qui
raconte sur les bas-reliefs la conquête
de la dacia ensuite il ya tous les rites
qui se passe sur le navire cette fois
par exemple ou bien peindre à l'avant de
la coque des yeux que l'on dit
prophylactique
de cette façon le bateau peut voir les
fonds de l'eau et prévenir l'arrivée
d'un danger malheureusement on ne
retrouve pas la trace de ses peintures
sur les épaves antiques l'on ne connaît
de bonnes représentation grâce aux
mosaïques et aux fresques antiques
représentants d'eads à venir d'ailleurs
on retrouve ses yeux sur beaucoup
d'embarcations traditionnelles à
différents endroits du globe au 19e
siècle au vietnam ou connaît le rituel
du don de l'âme et d'ouverture des dieux
du bateau c'est une cérémonie durant
laquelle ou pain à l'avant du bateau
ces fameux lieu magique on aménage
toujours à la proust à dire à l'avant un
hôtel sur lequel on pose des offrandes
de la nourriture de l'encens de la
vaisselle
mais aussi de l'argent l'autre élément
de l'embarcation qui recevait dans
l'antiquité des décorations c'est bien
entendu lancre langue c'est l'instrument
fondamental de contrôle du navire
servant à l'accostage émotif inscrit
dessus sont variés et en lien avec le
milieu marin ou les activités
commerciales
on retrouve des dauphins des coquillages
des osselets des tête de méduse
évidemment il ya toujours plusieurs
ancres sur un bateau questions de
sécurité et celle qui reçoit le plus
d'attention c'est lancre de miséricorde
encre sacré car elle constitue le plus
grand équipement du navire est utilisée
en dernier recours
lors d'une tempête pour avoir les dieux
avec eux durant le voyage les marins
antiquités emporte à bord des objets de
culte comme des petits hôtels ou des
répliques de temples mais aussi des
statuettes en bronze ou en bois
représentant dé dieu neptune prix
adaptés au foro et tout ça on connaît
grâce aux découvertes de l'archéologie
sous marine
et puis il ya les objets que l'on porte
sur soi au cours de ces fouilles il
arrive que l'on met au jour des
amulettes des bacs gravé mais aussi des
pierres transformer en pendentif les
pierres les plus appréciés était le
corindon la hyacinthe le corail
considérée comme une pierre à l'époque
leur efficacité a été renforcée si elles
étaient gravés ou sculptées comme ce
talisman en forme de phallus découvert à
bord de l'épave antici terre enfin un
dernier rite consiste à placer une
monnaie lors de la construction du
bateau à l'endroit où l'on vient mettre
le masque on appelle la plante sûrs en
europe jusque dans les années 80 on
trouvait encore de telles pratiques sur
les bateaux à voile en bois assez époque
récente les explications de ces dépôts
souligne une double intention date et la
construction du bateau et porté chance
chez les anciens les monnaies avait sans
doute cette fonction de porte bonheur
mais pas celle de datation car les
monnaies dont le métal n'est pas trop
codé et dont la date de frappe et
lisible ne correspondent pas à la date
de construction du navire en archéologie
n'ya pas encore d'explications claires
pour cette pratique du dépôt monétaire
il est des cas connus dans l'entité qui
s'en rapprochent comme le fait de placer
une monnaie dans un mur ou sous une
pierre de fondation lors de la
construction d'une maison ou de mettre
une pièce dans la bouche du mort pour
qu'il paye à charron le passeur d âme
le prix de l'au delà et si on revient à
une époque plus proche de nous on
connaît en chine méridionale jusqu'au
xxème siècle des rituels similaire avant
le départ l'équipage jeter de piles
navires des petits papiers dorés par
dessus bord cette couleur doré était
volontairement choisi pour rappeler le
métal des pièces de monnaie au japon
également aux bnr funa damas déesse
protectrice des pêcheurs et des
navigateurs pour lui rendre culte la
coutume consiste à creuser une qualité
dans le main et d'y introduire 12 pièces
de monnaie
ces exemples nous montre les qualités
magique qui sont attribués aux monnaies
leur pouvoir tout comme leur valeur
marchande est abstrait ou du moins
invisible quand on y réfléchit les
pièces n'ont de valeur que si l'on
adhère au système monétaire si on croit
à cette valeur ce ne sont que de simples
morceaux de métal qui sont investis d'un
pouvoir d'achat les marranes antiquités
pouvait aussi leur donner un autre
pouvoir celui de les protéger de les
amener à bon port
au final ces superstitions témoigne des
craintes qui sont indissociables de
l'inconnu et ce à toutes les époques le
voyage et à plus forte raison le voyage
en mer fera toujours partie des
expériences les plus puissantes de la
vie solitude apprentissage aventures et
rencontres de l'étranger comme je le
disais au début de cette vidéo la mer
reste un milieu hostile et tous les
marins d'aujourd'hui même les plus sains
croyants ont des accès de ferveur
religieuse pendant les tempêtes
pas étonnant donc qu'on continue
d'emporter avec soi un bout de cette
terre ferme
un objet du quotidien qui nous rassure
et nous permet d'avancer comme le
faisait déjà les navigateurs antique
mesdames et messieurs
si votre capitaine j'espère que vous
avez effectué une agréable croisière en
notre compagnie
moi et tout l'équipage à bord nous vous
invitons à cliquer sur le lien tipi en
fin d'épisode pour participer ainsi au
bon entretien du navire passé sauvage
passer d'agréables fêtes de fin d'année
à l'année prochaine